tomorrow night 48 hours tells the story
of a decades-old murder case and shows
how the victim's family is doing after
the killer was released from prison a
teenage boy named eric smith was
convicted in 1994 of murdering
four-year-old derrick roby in western
new york smith was freed last month
after nearly three decades senior
national correspondent jim axelrod spoke
with roby's parents in their first
extensive interview since smith's
release
[Music]
in 1993 thirteen-year-old eric smith
killed four-year-old derek roby in a fit
of rage
he was convicted and locked up for 28
years
then last month he was set free smith
has been paroled to queens new york i
understand why after so many years they
decided to give him a chance
and
that's fine
you know
for
him and his family
for derrick's parents dale and doreen
roby it begins a new chapter after
fighting for so long to keep smith in
prison you know he's been released
but in a way so have we no more parole
i can get on with
our lives
now the true healing can begin
to do that the robies have chosen to
focus on family and friends
and the joyful memories of their beloved
son
august 2nd the day we lost him we always
try to go do something fun
white ice cream with sprinkles
that's what derek called vanilla so we
try to do a
[Music]
wherever we are we have to go have
let's go find ice cream
[Music]
even though it's sad it's happy
you know
and jim axelrod is here with us jim you
know i feel their pain and it feels
fresh that's the thing when i watch that
interview it feels fresh what else did
they tell you look nearly three decades
these are
remarkable people um
it is
heartbreaking to sit with them the thing
that was most impressive to me when when
you talk to them you know you realize
they have a life sentence of their own
that they're serving right because they
will take the pain and the trauma of
their son's murder
to their grain right
what they talk about you heard it
briefly there that this parole of eric
smith actually liberates them and what
what uh doreen roby told me when i said
so what are you thinking she goes i'll
tell you what i'm not thinking i'm not
thinking about eric smith anymore and
that is its own value i don't need to
think about them i can just do whatever
i need to to move on with my life jim uh
as always fascinating reporting thank
you very much you can see more of jim's
report eric smith gambling on a killer
on 48 hours tomorrow night at 10 9
central right here on cbs and on our
streaming service paramount plus